[Música]
olá
votaram todos meu nome é no jardim
inferno convidaram para vir aqui falar
um grande sobre neurociências no
contexto das raízes e quando receber
este convite pensei vou ter de preparar
uma forma superficial protex n forma foi
ter uma crise de sinusite para vocês
terem a oportunidade da vida também não
pode ser violada por que dar todo um
outro impacto seria alcançável partilhar
convosco carinho das minhas raízes
porque afinal é isso que deve ser feito
de histórias em um percurso de
neurociências começou cedo como um dos
melhores professores que eu já tive
disse moita power the magnificent
powerful oz processo da power nenhuma
dor e passou a traduzir o maior poderio
da terra é um magnífico poder que todos
nós possuímos o poder do cérebro porque
está a questionar se foi professor
charles xavier o cheiro mesmo uma boa
por curso intensivo por que não deixar
fascinar por esta máquina misteriosa que
é o cérebro e pulmão super-heróis
serviço nem poder controlar objetos
momento dominar a arca turquia e até de
controlar os pensamentos dos outros
então seria estudar um pouco mais sobre
o senhor é pra mim aquilo que eu chamo
servos não é mais que um conjunto de
células comunicam entre si através de
impulsos elétricos pikitim uma chilena é
que grande parte dos componentes
necessários por esta comunicação foram
encontrados em organismos unicelulares
ao longo de milhões de anos
esses organismos foram se agrupando
especializando no envio de mensagens
dando origem ao sistema nervoso nervoso
e esta só então as raízes do nosso
cérebro
esta história hoje temos uma diversidade
e destreza sessão de atribuição
significado ao momento temos a
capacidade de aprendizagem e planeamento
e ainda que algumas pessoas façam isto
não usar temos a capacidade de se
colocar no lugar do outro e fiquei ainda
mais intrigado
seria de esperar que o filme milhões de
anos de evolução já fosse os mestres
neto dominar certo mas não conseguiu
fazê lo quando era mais nova minha mãe
está aqui é o novo investimento
às vezes a fase asneiras e depois dizia
a oka noite também fechou e ela muito
serena falar comigo daquela forma que as
mães sabem falar mais nem pensar e dizer
gostei de aprender com as pessoas que
fazem melhor que tu não te faz pior e eu
pensei fazer algum sentido em tentar mas
não precisa de muito tempo até perceber
que estava muito longe de atingir um
objetivo
não consegui aprender sal cria e pior do
que isso continuava sem conseguir de
pensamentos dos outros por mais
concentradas existir não era uma opção
estava determinada a encontrar essas
respostas por isso foi para mim um dos
cruzamentos mais importantes da minha
vida
hoje eu tenho duas opções ou estudava
psicologia ou aprender a ser vivente
foi uma escolha difícil confesso mas foi
também pioneiro psicologia e descobri
que o cérebro é demasiado complexo e que
as nossas escolhas e aprendizagem são
mais difíceis de perceber do que fazer
nós crescemos como a idéia do super
poder controlar a mente dos outros que
nem nos apercebemos no qual imitar sons
no controle da nossa não existe nenhum
super herói com um super poder controlar
a própria mente e sejamos sinceros seria
o pior super herói da história
eu consigo não pensar num porco a andar
de bicicleta sempre que alguém me
imaginam porque andava e 50 não teria
piada nenhuma acho que só o aquaman
gostaria porque deixaria de ser um dos
40 mais inútil para passar a cereja que
eu tenho manhã
não venho aqui partilhar convosco
se nós conseguirmos controlar o nosso
cérebro é prendendo criamos as nossas
raízes iluminando a fiocruz limita eram
os mais céticos e que estaria baseado
óbvio mas basta olharmos para o estado
atual da política mundial que percebemos
que não é assim tão fácil aprendemos com
as nossas raízes
mas para perceber onde eu quero chegar
vamos olhar para o assunto alguns dos
neurociências
de uma forma muito simplista nós
aprendemos e nosso cérebro aprende
através da potência
vamos fortalecendo ligações em redes
neuronais nas áreas determinadas tarefa
e vamos ficar melhor desempenho do mesmo
mal
nós perdemos ligações e vamos esquecendo
de outras coisas mas mesmo assim nada
garantido
toda a gente que está aqui ou foi meu
colega na escola por mais que a
professora tens alguma coisa chegava até
se dar uma resposta errada mas pressa
porque tal como jogos de computador
existem paul apps como por exemplo haver
uma forte rali no final cielo porque nós
nunca nos esquecemos das duas vergonhas
mais ou menos pois passamos
estou aqui falaram que ele em tom de
brincadeira mas imagine por exemplo um
caso de bullying é muito provável que
essa pessoa tenha sofrido baixa
autoestima e não é porque simplesmente o
sérvio foi gravando programas executados
do que tudo que faço está em casa e vai
ser alvo de críticas
infelizmente eu não fui o único a
acreditar ser esta brincadeira já com o
sol os anjos começaram a ser feitos
registros
e foi neste papel de atividade elétrica
em atenas em folhas de papel os
conhecidos eletroencefalograma elas a
que estamos habituados a ver nos tetos
mente este permitiu que nós conseguimos
prever é que serve funciona com ondas
diferentes frequências em diferentes de
150 atividades ou seja dependendo
daquilo que estivermos a fazer e da zona
que tiveram de analisar e vamos
encontrar padrões de ondas rápidas e
lentas distribuídos formas diferentes
isto foi o é obviamente foi um grande
avanço mas não foi suficiente para
conseguir obter respostas necessárias
até que um engenheiro e marketing
conseguiu fazer estes registos em fita
magnética circuit ou o google
revolucionou um profundo o estudo sério
mas ao mesmo tempo fosse com você leitor
uma análise quantitativa dos dados e com
o consequente mas um mapeamento cerebral
mas equipamentos usados são registados
são analisados através de formas
na época de processamento senão e são
posteriormente comparados com dados
normativos sendo provável
psicofisiologia conseguindo se aos
padrões de atividade cerebral
determinadas funções e viola surgem
milhares de possibilidades
5 - aqui também as técnicas da
imagiologia
então esse número cresce ainda mais é
neste contexto que surgem as técnicas do
túnel na mudança
a partir daqui basta seguir os
protocolos de estimulação prossegue com
o trabalho da forma que nosso cliente
uma dessas técnicas a 19 ver o que é que
eu faço a maior parte do dia e passo a
explicar
acho que ninguém vai finalmente perceber
aquilo que eu faço mas aqui mesmo eu
coloco sensores na zona do cérebro que
não vou trabalhar da mesma forma que vai
fazer um registo e assim não é
processado em tempo real ea ouvir o
feedback a pessoa é visual e auditiva de
uma forma muito genérica sempre observo
estiver a trabalhar né
a pessoa vai ter um feedback positivo
quando estiver vai ter um feedback
negativo simples estreia repetitivo vai
ensinar o cérebro a trabalhar então na
forma desejada e conseqüentemente
reduzir sintomas
dando o exemplo prático para ser mais
fácil de perceber e imaginem uma pessoa
que tenha poucas ondas cap daniel
frontal é um programa típico desta terça
no meu filho vem vamos tentar colocar as
tensões nessa zona que estava a fazer o
registo civil se tiver a trabalhar com
mais 12 rápidas porque o que nós
queremos conversar e queremos que
aconteça a pessoa vai ter um feedback
positivo
eu sei que isso parece ser um filme de
ficção científica mas é real e funciona
a respeito da atual unidade então menor
desde quando estes clínicos e sintomas
como ansiedade depressão déficit de
atenção e hiperatividade ou até a
otimização de performance como devem
calcular exatamente expressivo este é
apenas o primeiro passo
imaginem todas as possibilidades
só por curiosidade augusto maneira
alguma coisa sobre nanotecnologia
então posso dizer com uma sequência não
acreditar em tudo está perfeito
é verdade que eu disse isso não há
tecnologia começam a ser mais freqüentes
mesmo por quem nos procura
principalmente ao nível do interface
cérebro-computador no campo do seu uso é
novo lançar não é o único caminho a ser
traçado
um dos exemplos mais conhecidos é
leitura dos sinais elétricos e elétricos
10 para o controle dos jogos já é
possível controlar capuz e um
helicóptero só com o pensamento imaginei
um carinho pela comunidade
só que em vez das duas instituições
através do documento é só com o
pensamento pensamento vai para a direita
o craque vai para a direita pensando na
esquerda e que ninguém vai pra esquerda
não vai ser incrível ter um dos robôs
que fazem aquilo que nós pensamos
mas mais importante que isso é a
diferença significativa que isto irá ter
na vida de uma pessoa paraplégica por
exemplo o objectivo é conseguirmos criar
- robóticos que responda à perfeição o
nosso pensamento que sejam no fundo
parto nós estamos ainda mais a mãe
recentemente foi possível a partilha de
informação diretamente entre cérebros
foram colocadas três pessoas entre as
salas diferentes sendo que são entre
elas e por equipe para jogar em um jogo
que o técnico não se conhecem mas é um
jogo que nos blocos que vão querendo e
temos de encaixar na parte baixa só
estamos falando de um blog onde encaixar
este não então jogar este jogo só com o
pensamento
duas delas tenham acesso ao ecrã
completo é que saiba só conseguiu virar
para cima
os dois primeiros tenham então de olhar
para o jogo e perceber se é preciso
mudar o bloco ou não podiam encaixar em
uma semana registando enviada para
professor esta conseguiu receber a
informação e aplicar um jogo ou soja
mesmo se conseguir ver a parte de baixo
consigo perceber será necessário fundar
o bloco não podiam encaixar em breve
único imitando a tecnologia e ao
desenvolvimento tecnológico será a nossa
própria imaginação
ouvimos muitas vezes favela frase a isto
agora essa tecnologia no meu tempo é que
era a verdade é que para muitas pessoas
o desenvolvimento tecnológico é uma
verdadeira cidade e o comper tradições
outro do próprio humanismo que nos
caracteriza
eu sou otimista gosto de ver o copo meio
cheio
e por isso vou terminar voltando ao
início
não seria ótimo se conseguíssemos
escolher aquilo que aprendemos as nossas
raízes pois eu escolhi manter constante
curiosidade o dizer não à estagnação é
procura todos conhecido em busca de
novas formas de melhorar a nossa
qualidade de vida possam chegar a ter
superpoderes com que sonhava mas sei que
todos os dias e cada vez mais têm a
possibilidade de melhorar a vida de
várias pessoas e esse é o nosso
português que eu poderia ter
gabriela
[Aplausos]
[Música]